I received an email from Alan which I'm
going to show you and it's related to
the Olympics he said David I'd like to
know why there have been no reports in
the mainstream media or even on online
news sources such as TYT Tom Hartman
secular talk or yourself concerning the
incidents of anti-semitic / anti Israeli
behavior at the Olympics such as the
Lebanese team trainer refusing to allow
the Israeli team on the bus or the
Egyptian judoka refusing to shake his
Israeli opponents hand after the match
the world seems to watch everything
Israel does with a microscope but turns
a blind eye
whenever the slights are against Israel
we'll listen I can't speak for the other
shows right I've had these stories
bookmarked and just haven't gotten to
them but let's look at it and you're
absolutely right Alan that there is an
obsession with Israel for many for some
it's rooted in anti-semitism for others
it's rooting and pushing what they
believe to be progressive ideas or
something but as I've said before anti
Israeli bias goes way beyond what makes
sense over policy disagreements as well
as anti-semitism and we know that
anti-semitism is way more acceptable
than many other types of discrimination
today in 2016 the 2016 Summer Olympics
have been happening in Brazil there's
been a number of really horrible
incidents one is that Lebanese Olympians
refuse to travel on the same bus as the
Israeli Olympians and some were even
trying to block the Israeli athletes
from getting on the bus as Israeli
players tried to get on the bus uh
the head of the Lebanese Olympic
delegation tried to block the aisle and
the entrance and eventually to avoid an
incident another bus was sent for the
Lebanese players in the Israeli players
ultimately got on the bus that they were
assigned to if your reaction when I tell
you this is that hey people are standing
up when they see injustice in Israel's
policy and that's what these actions
were with regard to the bus think about
it for a second if US Olympians try to
get on a bus with its Hallion Olympians
and the Italians didn't want the US
Olympians on the bus because their away
their their way against the drone policy
of the United States
would people be supporting that or would
they say hey these are American athletes
they don't have anything to do with
drones you're being fools but somehow
with Israel Louis it doesn't make the
headlines in the same way there's a
different standard applied yeah uh those
who are obsessed with the BDS movement
don't seem to be concerned with any
other country in the world that might be
uh perpetrating some type of human
rights violation if you ask them they
say they are concerned with that but
they're not of course they're not they
they dedicate what why do we never hear
them talk about people who were
displaced and and and and out of their
ancestral homes in China
or what's going on in North Korea or
what's going on in Sudan or slave labor
in Qatar or you name it uh the list goes
on and on but these people are not
trying to to fight any of that they are
not speaking out about any of that it's
only Israel another example is that on
his way to the finals in the men's
hundred kilogram plus judo weight class
Israeli judoka or sets on defeated an
Egyptian named islam al shahab II and
after us asan or Sasson defeated Elsa
hobby and attempted to shake hands you
know sportsmanship Elsa hobby refused
and here is a picture of that going on
imagine Michael Phelps in a swimmer from
Spain on the metal podium and after the
anthem is played Michael Phelps goes to
shake hands with the Spanish swimmer and
the swimmer refuses because he doesn't
like American foreign policy who would
support that
and Elsa hobby was reportedly under
pressure from Islamic groups and
Egyptian nationalists not to even fight
or Sasson to just back out altogether I
guess we should be glad he didn't at
least do that and then the stories
continue there was an Olympic qualifying
match uh and a lot got soon who's a
boxer from Syria just flat-out refused
to fight an Israeli athlete and go soon
said that competing with an israeli
athlete would mean that he recognizes
the State of Israel so like I said many
times this isn't just about justice for
Palestinians in the West Bank and Gaza
very clearly for some it is that they
don't even want to wreck
knives that Israel is a country this is
a completely laughable position in 2016
another judo fighter reportedly
forfeited a match also so is not to face
an Israeli athlete
unfortunately these stories haven't
actually made much news there is one
story related to Israel in the Olympics
that I've seen among the so called left
and it's a story about how Palestinian
swimmer Marie al-atrash supposedly had
no way of training in an Olympic sized
pool because as the story goes there are
none in the Palestinian territories and
she just can't get a pool to practice in
imagine uh the the UH confusion when I
looked into this and it turns out that
the story is not even true Israeli
officials made it clear that first of
all marry all at Rosh never even
requested a permit to train in Jerusalem
which would have been granted and she
would have been able to train in
Jerusalem and it's also been pointed out
that there are several Olympic size
pools in the Palestinian territories and
it is so disappointing Lois when the
insane anti Israeli bias that some call
anti-semitism in these particular cases
is basically ignored but a non-story
crafted merely for PR value that is
demonstrably false is the one story that
makes it into media more broadly
speaking it's already disappointing
pastor said this is a microcosm of the
whole thing because everyone who is so
uh uh you know crazy with this BDS stuff
in the Israel stuff they are victims of
what might be the world's one of the
world's best propaganda movements and
propaganda machines not to say that
Israel has done nothing wrong believe me
they have there's plenty of stuff we can
point out of course but uh but still
there is this gigantic propaganda
machine around the whole Israel
Palestine conflict and uh and that's why
none of these people care about anything
else that's happening in the world
they are only focused on Israel